قاده الجيش الاثيوبي وجبه تيغراي تباحه في
العاصمه الكينيه نيروبي شروط نزع سلاح
مسلح الجبهه المصوص عليه في اتفاق السلام
مستشار الامن القومي اكد ان مخرجات هذا
الحوار بين القيادات العسكريه سيقدم خارطه
الطريق لتفعيل السلام
ربما بحلول نهايه هذا الاسبوع او بحلول
بدايه الاسبوع المقبل بمجرد ان يتوصل
القاده العسكريون الى اتفاق ويخبرونا
بكيفيه التنسيق سنبدا العمل ونسمح لشاحنات
باحضار المساعدات الغذائيه لا ينبغي ان
يستغرق الامر مناما بعد توافقهم
يفترضون يسهم الاتفاق الموقعه في الثاني
من نوفمبر في وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
ونهايه الحرب التي اندلعت في نوفمبر من
عام 2020 بين متمردي تكراي والجيش
الاثيوبيه
كلما زادت ثقه الناس وزاد املهم عند رؤيه
ما نفعله على الارض كل ما قل احتماله قيام
اشخاص مثلي ومثل زميلي رضوان بتدمير امل
الجنود في وقف اطلاق النار
تاكد بشكل مطلق كانت الاعمال العدائيه
توقفت لكن اكيد بحسب الامم المتحده ان
الطرف النزاع تورط في مقتل وتشريد مئات
الالاف من الاشخاص منذ بدء النزاع
[موسيقى]